we begin with breaking news from
afghanistan and the taliban says it
seized control of a border crossing with
pakistan
this footage has emerged showing taliban
fighters
at the gate the afghan government is
denying the armed group's claims
it says its forces repelled taliban
fighters
the spinball duck border crossing
connects the city of kandahar directly
with pakistan
and is a major supply line for whoever
controls it
joins us now live from the pakistani
capital islamabad
and what are you hearing from your
sources about what exactly is happening
at that border crossing
well we do know that there's been some
fighting
at that border crossing it's been baldar
which is a district
of kandahar province this is a key
area because it straddles the main
highway from
the city of quetta in pakistan to
kandahar it's a major logistical route
the taliban have sent us images which
show
that they've been hoisting their flags
at the border post
their soldiers or fighters present at
that particular location
which is not surprising given the fact
that they have also taken over a key
border post with iran at islam killer
they've taken a border post at sunday
which
is the border with turkmenistan and
earlier had taken
a border post on the tajik border
forcing many soldiers to flee across
so it is indeed an important development
because it appears
the taliban are trying not just to
control the main
entry points from their neighboring
countries but also going for key
districts and surrounding major cities
pakistan on the other hand of course is
bracing
for more fighting in afghanistan it has
warned that a political solution is
important
and absolutely necessary because it
fears that refugees may start pouring
into pakistan on which
count the pakistanis said that they will
not allow any more refugees across the
border so indeed
a fluid situation although the afghan
authorities may be denying this
we have received images that clearly
show the taliban hosting their flags at
that key border crossing
at spin baldur some afghan officials
accuse pakistan of supporting the
taliban and have for a long time how is
pakistan likely to respond
to these developments at the border
well such accusations are not new there
be there's been a
war of words between the two countries
it should not be forgotten
that pakistan has been a key facilitator
in trying to bring the taliban and the
americans to a negotiated settlement
pakistan saying that it does not have
any favorites in afghanistan
however the government in kabul has been
constantly accusing pakistan
the pakistanis on the other hand saying
that the afghan authorities are turning
a blind eye to
teddy taliban pakistan fighters who are
based just across the border in
afghanistan
so the war of words of course will
continue but pakistan has made it very
clear
that it will not allow any more afghan
refugees to come across and that
it is not choosing sides the foreign
minister also saying that a political
settlement
was extremely crucial within the upfront
parties
and that this has to be upgrade led up
on own however the taliban appeared to
be on the offensive they have gained
key ground they of course claim 85
percent which is disputed by the
government of afghanistan
so it'll be important to see whether the
taliban are able to hold on to their
gains
uh in spielbald and also the possibility
that they may even go for
torquam which is the major crossing from
the kaiba book to hua province and the
major logistical supply line after spin
baldur
through pakistan all right thank you
very much for that update there kamal
harder
live from islamabad